[Music]
in human hotpot news oh I hope it's not
a horror story submitted by fried sushi
how fitting a hotel in China opened a
hotpot themed spa with actual veggies in
the water
what well it could still be a horror
story however did you treat the soup
like you go like like that that means if
it's a mushroom that Japan already did
the ramen one yeah but this is how nasty
do they eat the food so they are eating
fresh Lisa this is a troubling game how
much thick cheese is in that water
yeah as you know there are circumcised
so they're eating and like passing food
I know there's real you don't know you
know little boys don't know how to wash
their ass yet like real veggie wait I
don't think they're eating the veggies
that's in the water
no skewers but I'm like I don't know but
they do mention that how is it a hovered
next time hmm
I guess it's kind of cool if you come
out smelling like apples or something
chili the chili one seems dangerous
decision because the chili one is like I
could burn my dick off this is like when
I was a kid and you're waiting for the
Autopia cars yeah oh I hope I get the
red one it's like oh I hope I get
lettuce or tomatoes I'm a bok choy this
just reminds me of a YouTube video that
like someone [ __ ] takes a bath with
skittles or some jelly where is this in
in China is the food that means serve is
the way you're cooking it how long has
the vegetables been in the water all
right I don't know album each person
I hope that they don't use it for dinner
they take it and then they go through
the time I need to get a soup hey they
drink it to boil so it gets rid all the
germ ease like lettuce chili peppers
mushrooms apples and bananas banana all
about the closest thing to that is my
mom would get tangerine peels and then
throw that inside the bath that makes
sense like what does that do to smell
good it's like infuses the water and
like I guess the pule like it it smells
pretty good Romo therapy because people
actually you guys heard about the orange
showers it's like you would go in the
shower and then you actually just eat an
orange or like Clementine tangerine what
cuz looks like a nice way to start your
day you you can clean obviously and then
there's you know how it's messy when
you're eating that [ __ ] like if I finger
is true while you're in the shower you
can clean I just feel weird eating in
the shower in the shower I do the thing
where you get like dry coffee grounds I
fill up with a hot water one thing I've
even done coffee shower yeah
even embarrassed to say now is like I've
eaten like I finished my food while
taking a [ __ ] like that looks pretty
long that one was hard you have the more
you stuff term a taco no wait you're
like you're like tender I just don't
like eating cold food it's too good not
to things like two stops I'm pooping and
I'm going I'm like oh do we get true
there are microwaves these days yeah
this morals
I tried all right now I felt safe in
this review forever free tacos and
[ __ ] even I wouldn't do that
dude I'm I'm such a weirdo I'll take my
movie theater drink into the dudes
bathroom and I'll throw away the [ __ ]
straw after cuz all the [ __ ] you can
like you open that thing and you can
feel the particulates in the air I'll
take my risks being roofied because what
I do is leave it outside and walk into
the bathroom and come out and get it Wow
worse what if someone goes
this and then go I don't know what I do
I would they do that happens all the
time I just put on the urinal and I just
peed you got pee pee splash dude you
don't like [ __ ] feel it when you open
that door you can feel all the urine in
the man [ __ ] I do i do I just blow it
the particular it's illegal oh that's
smart that's really smart you're hot
Bret burns all that [ __ ] Jeremy's off
Isaac it's pretty hot oh yeah it smells
like business suits and farts in the
guy's restroom at the airport and Pete
farts right you know I'm talking about
like I think the only thing that I can
take into the bathroom and be
comfortable consuming is like alcohol in
a bathtub like in a bubble bath that's
it like I can't be in there a nice drink
yeah you're right even bats are kind of
nasty to me I'm trying to redeem myself
here okay okay let's hear it bats
I think they're nasty in general yeah
well I have to shower after a bath yeah
can't just be like cool I took a bath
I'm out no I need a shower all the grimy
[ __ ] cuz you're laying in your grimy
yeah yeah yeah exactly I'm just like how
is this relaxing I'm just thinking about
all the nest what just a ton of soap in
there you're scrubbing yourself awful
although I'm just soaking in the [ __ ]
thing now I find soaking in it but I
preferred you to wash it off before I
leave and then I feel guilty because I
just wasted so much water so I'm guilty
I feel guilty there's so much water in
the ocean it's like impossible think
about it it's my cuz we're in LA yeah
the droughts always drove in our head
and then in Mexico growing up Mexican
we're always really cautious of not we
see water yeah because it's like cactus
everywhere and it's desert so it's a
very different world I mean know where
my family's probably just the entire
well when I picture Mexico am i stereo
to the typical mind
yeah there's a tumbleweed
it's like person gets set to have to
drink that
xxx yeah xxx tea anyway yeah would you
guys ever go to this hotpot yam down oh
god good people watch hell yeah I'll go
anywhere two people watch it there's
people naked in a bath you like yeah and
you're this white guy this tall white
guy that's like why would I hold bananas
like their guns
how would you hold it then hold it
unthreatening Lee you have a good cool
that's cool
you have to show them your palms exactly
[ __ ] weird isn't he employee now you
just look insane that's that's you're
making a weird man yeah that is my being
so weird man a baby that's weirder bro
oh no okay that's okay that's cool yeah
I'm threatening no that's an invitation
do to the wrong person that shit's a
[ __ ] cow chase it's like prison when
you pull your pocket out yeah yeah and
then someone like somebody like if Joe
was to take my place right now if I was
holding it's not gear like he's my [ __ ]
yeah and we walk yeah
you know why can't it just be between
there no one else gets it yeah and don't
[ __ ] with me that don't hurt me what if
he wants more than one I'm his property
to hold two pockets yeah you can't
that's that's when you know you're the
real man in jail yeah you got to [ __ ]
pockets Isaac ain't just walking around
yeah what if you're right one of those
pants that has with fake pockets and
it's soda a prison everyone wears the
same be somebody's [ __ ] then you're
probably somebody's [ __ ] huh Parker you
pull those pockets under heaven you're
gonna have like six people oh yeah the
ones that you can't pull out yeah see
he's somebody's [ __ ] he's somebody's
mention he's dude you haven't seen the
scared straight or what that was like
hold my pocket
I remember this now exactly did you ever
watch good shape yeah
I'm not that absurd yeah you missed it
it's good clearly [ __ ] I'm writing all
these down no this is great information
I remember when you know back in the day
when they had those talk shows
and then the kids will come out all bold
and [ __ ] like Montel oh just jealous
you're just jealous with girls
yeah cuz I'm wondering what would catch
a psychic girl would look like in one of
those situations oh she's probably cry
Bobby she would never have in it I saw
this one where there was like this chick
that was like 6 4 there's just Samoan
and then like she looked to a look at
another girl she would just smile and
she just looks like a jack-o'-lantern
cuz all her teeth fell from meth I
didn't imagine I get a 13 year old cache
miss I'd really just see like so you
wanna be in here [ __ ] just be so
[ __ ] scary that she would just cry
yeah she would just cry cuz once the
lights turn out she's like that doesn't
go on in there oh man I kind of want to
see that it's too late now though yeah
she's really she's bawling non-lawyers
now Oh remember that when they used to
go to boot camp they always had like a
drill sergeant yelling in their faces
and [ __ ] no Thank You nose hit the
[ __ ] babe yeah yeah so they're good
and then they always have like the Hat
like all the way here and then that
[ __ ] thing
yeah well dude my um my brother was tell
me cuz he's in the Air Force he said
they can't even yell they can't curse
anymore yeah so when the drill sergeants
like up in your face yeah he's like okay
it said the same I can see like that
he's like they can't do this [ __ ] do you
used to do how do they prepare you well
maybe that's the Air Force because maybe
the Marines still like Clarke or because
don't they could be hella racial hell
everything I tell her everything I mean
it could be but I've also heard like in
the army they have stress cars know if
it's like everyone gets a stress car
exactly like if it's too stressful you
pull it out so you could take a break
like take a breather from it and then
you have to come back like 10 Jude but
who knows maybe the next war will be a
millennial war by both sides so both
smart and hey that's cool no problem
sorry sorry about that but the missiles
only and the air every time they cuss it
for the point of the swear jar right
exactly
I have paid for the other the opponent's
war phone
[Music]